(audience applauding)
- Have you ever met Jenna, Sam,
I don't know if anybody's ever met.
- No, I haven't.
- Okay, say hi.
I'm bringing people together.
- Very nice to meet you.
- Hi.
- Yeah, I have to admit longtime fan.
- Oh of me?
- So excited to be sitting here
with you.
- Oh.
- A little nervous.
- Oh I have to admit,
I always love when people
that work out all the time
use my music to work out and I don't,
(group laughing)
That's my favorite part.
They're like, oh, we use you
in our class all the time,
I was like, I wouldn't know.
(all laughs)
But I love that, thank you,
that's such a compliment
and I love your hair,
I'm complimenting that as well.
'Cause it's same.
- Yeah, it's so cute.
- Oh, so cute.
- You would look cute.
- Anyway, I know.
- Have you, I feel like
you're one of those people,
you set a goal and you kill it every time,
are you one of those people
that ever breaks your resolution?
- I generally do.
I have to admit, when it comes to health,
that is my job, I'm good at it.
- Yeah.
- But I make resolutions
outside of health and then
I fail every single time,
'cause that's why it's my resolution
- That makes me feel good.
- 'Cause I can't do it.
- Yeah.
- So like, I have tried to quit swearing.
- Oh.
- For two decades.
- Why?
(group laughing)
- Good, that's exactly
why I gave up on it.
- I mean, my mom will actually yeah,
she tells me it's trashy,
but like, whatever.
- So is my wife, she's like,
you just literally, you sound so trashy,
you would sound so much more-
- But doesn't it feel good?
- It feels amazing.
- And you can swear intelligently.
- That's what,
thank you.
- For Sure.
- Thank you so much.
In fact, there's a study that came out.
- What is it?
- What's that?
- Intelligent people swear
so now I just hang my hat on
like I'm exceptionally intelligent.
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
- I just tried to narrow
it down to time and place,
like, I won't drop the
F-bomb here on your show.
- Okay.
- Probably on my way
to the car I'll find a reason.
- Reason, yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's all right, I like it.
But so for anyone wanting to make changes,
it's hard, it's hard to stick with it,
I think or I've been
told, with discipline.
(all laughs)
So how do you sustain it?
Like for the long haul?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it's really
a life choice.
I feel like a lot of us will be like,
I just wanna do this,
let's see if I can do it for three months,
but it's really a life decision right?
- So, I wanna get a little
bit more serious on you now,
and try to address two
different kinds of people.
The first one is the one that
the type of person that
has been approaching me
for the last several weeks,
the one that's like, ugh, I gained weight,
oh, I need to look a girl,
I need to lose 30 pounds,
and I'm like, stop.
And by the way, the years have
not been kind as we all know,
and it comes from the place
of like beating yourself up,
feeling disappointed with yourself.
And that's the self-loathing
thing nobody wants, right?
But then the antidote to that
is the nah, girl, you're good.
And the truth of the matter is,
when you get into that conversation,
you rob yourself of all
of this excellent growth
that you can make a-
- Potential of it.
- In any facet
of your life, right?
We wanna evolve, grow,
whether it's mental health,
physical health, relationships, career.
- All of the above what?
- All of you at inception
come from a place
of wanting to be healthy
because you love your body
not because you hate it.
- [Molly] Yeah.
- And when you begin a
journey with that intention,
the next step is to
really identify your why.
So far greater minds than me have said,
if you have a why, you
can tolerate the how.
Work with purpose becomes passion,
work without it is gonna feel punishing.
So you better outline
like, why am I doing this?
- Yeah.
- Is this a change
I really care about?
How will my life be better?
And I don't mean I wanna be healthy,
that means nothing to me.
I don't even know what that means,
it's, I'm getting married this summer,
and I want to feel my strongest,
most fit, healthiest best.
I wanna live to meet
my great-grandchildren,
I lost my mother to breast cancer
and I wanna live my
healthiest life in her honor
and raise money by running a marathon,
I don't care what it is.
- What your motivator.
- As long as it does motivate you.
And from that place
it helps you stay motivated
and make the healthier choice.
And then of course small changes
are generally best for people
because they're more accessible
and more sustainable.
- Attainable, yeah.
- And less overwhelming.
- Yeah, less overwhelming,
yeah, well, The Fitness
App by Jillian Michaels
is available for download
wherever you get your apps people.
Also be sure to check
out Jillian's podcast,
Keeping It Real.
I love keeping real, that's all.